- Now let's get to our first guest.
He put the Jack in "Will
& Grace" and he also
co-hosts the number one comedy podcast
in the world, "SmartLess".
His new podcast is called
"HypochondriActor",
which is awesome.
Please welcome Sean Hayes!
(upbeat music)
(applause and cheers)
- I have no where to go!
(upbeat music)
(laughter)
I'm not there yet!
- You're not there yet!
(upbeat music)
(laughter)
- Oh my God!
That was awesome.
- Nice, nice!
- That was awesome.
- [Sean] Nice.
- You win for best entrance,
or intro, yes entrance.
- Look at how gorgeous!
- Oh, I did nothing.
I showed up in my PJ's
and my team got ahold of
me like "Harry Potter".
(laughter)
- You want me to help you tie that?
- No, she had it tied and I
felt like I was gonna die.
No, I don't know how y'all do that.
- Too stuffy.
- The whole suit thing.
Yeah.
It's nice to have you here in person.
- It's so nice to see you.
How about you have a show?
- I know!
And it's doing all right, Sean!
- It's doing really well.
- This is a long way from
when we first were hanging
in "Hollywood Game Night", I think,
the first time I did, yeah-
- I know, you were so
nice to do that show.
- I'm very competitive, sorry.
- I love it.
- I know, I'm a lot.
- Kelly was so nice to do it.
I produced a show called
"Hollywood Game Night"
and you were on it
and we had so much fun.
- I love it,
I've done it twice!
- Yeah, I know.
- But how's your puppy?
Is he still chewing everything?
- My puppy, yes.
Yes, my puppy is chewing everything.
His name is Ricky, he's a golden doodle.
We call his mouth the chamber of secrets.
Oh, look it.
Wait a minute.
- [Kelly] Yes, 'cause I have Henry,
a golden doodle that's black and brown.
- Right, I remember this.
And that is nothing how he is now.
He's like a gigantic horse.
You could put a saddle on him and ride him
down the 101.
Look at how big he is.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- Isn't that crazy?
And he still thinks he's this big.
- I'm telling you what, golden doodle,
look at that face.
Movies should be made
because of this face.
- You're talking about the dog, or?
- Yes, unfortunately.
(laughter)
- Because it ain't
happening for the other one.
- No, it's just, I look
at that little, oh!
Golden doodles, their
little eyes, I love it.
I saw something though, it's a video.
I think we have it.
You're sneezing and you scared
the crap out of your dog.
I wanna show it.
- [Sean] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my God, that's right.
(Sean sneezes)
(dog barks)
- God!
- Sorry.
Sorry, that came out so fast.
- It was like a combination
of broken glass,
a scream and you stepping on his foot.
Oh my God.
(laughter)
- I love that your dog was like,
which orifice did that come from?
He's sniffing your butt.
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause I guess that's what my
toots sound like.
- Your toots would sound like.
Very happy.
A happy toot.
- No, but yeah that was crazy.
A sneeze like that and has
never come out of me before.
I had no idea why or how.
- [Kelly] Oh, I sneeze so loud.
- You do?
- I mean, is that shocking
that I do something loud?
No.
- No, no.
(laughter)
That's hilarious.
- It's not shocking.
No, my poor dog, Henry,
he's just like, calm down.
- Is he as big as Ricky?
- Here's the thing, did they lie to you?
Because like, I was told he's
gonna be 15 to 18 pounds,
like 45 pounds later.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Not 15 to 18,
which actually I like big dogs,
so I'm fine with it, but big!
- That's kind of like how my weight went
before and after COVID, right?
(laughter)
They were like, "You look great."
And I go, "Well I gained 20 pounds."
- Yeah, oh my gosh.
I keep running into these
people that lost weight.
I'm like, what's happening?
- I swear to God,
like two months ago, I
was like, joke's over.
I have got to lose.
I mean, I was-
- I say that, but I don't
follow through, Sean.
Everyone says it, but
you don't follow through.
Well, some people do apparently.
But I have to ask you
this, 'cause Joe Biden
is now president.
And I heard him say-
- What?
- I know, it's exciting.
(laughter)
- I thought it was still...
I thought there was no conceding.
- No, no, no.
- I didn't think he-
- He is president-
- So he won?
- I was there in the office with him.
- Okay great.
Oh, that's right!
- I was!
And he did say that "Will & Grace"
did more than anything else to shift
like how people viewed gay marriage.
And I never really thought about that,
but I think that's absolutely true.
- Isn't that amazing?
- Especially reaching
on a broad scale, like so many.
You're in the homes of, you
know, all across America.
- I mean, look, when I got the pilot,
which is the first episode,
I was 27 years old.
So just a couple of years ago, but I...
(laughter)
Thanks, that took
just a second.
- Me too.
Me too.
- But no, and I was just happy
to get a job on a TV show.
I had no idea that the
by-product would be something
that was bigger than all of us.
And then I'm sitting at
home on the couch one day.
I don't remember,
this is when Joe Biden
was the vice-president
and he said something on MSNBC
or I don't know, some show.
And he was like, "Will & Grace"
did more to educate America
about the gay movement than anything.
And I was like, what?
It was just crazy.
- I think it's true though,
art does inspire real life.
Real life inspires art, I
guess, same kind of thing.
But, but yeah, I think
it's absolutely true.
I just never thought about it.
- Also it's the power of comedy.
The power of comedy is the
ability to educate people
without them knowing it.
Because if they're enjoying you,
you can't combat that, right?
- Yeah, I agree.
His new podcast is called
"HypochondriActor",
which is genius.
He hosts it with a
talented and funny doctor
who is joining us now.
She's a double board certified
physician specializing
in internal medicine and obesity medicine.
Everybody say hello to Dr. Priyanka Wali!
(upbeat music)
(applause and cheers)
It's so funny when we
have more than one guest,
it's like, "What's up?"
- [Priyanka] Hello!
- I was gonna say, your one
more will be in the parking lot.
- I know, we've had it.
And I'm usually over here
and it's wrapped around.
It's funny.
How did you two meet?
- So...
- Do you wanna go?
- No, you go, you go.
- Well, okay, so I met with
Hazy Mills Productions,
which runs the podcast
and they pitched this idea
about wanting to do a medical podcast
that's funny and entertaining
and you know, I practice medicine
but I was also doing stand-up
comedy for all these years.
- [Kelly] Which I'm
gonna get to in a minute.
- Just let me interrupt.
She's this gorgeous Indian female
standup comedian-
- I'm kind of upset right now.
- Practicing board certified doctor.
- I'm upset, all those
things, you got all the cards.
All the cards.
- Let's explore that.
- Explore it away.
I'm an open book.
No, that's awesome though, stand-up,
it was so interesting
that you also did that.
- Yeah, totally.
But the reason I decided
to do the gig is basically
because you know, there's a lot of medical
information out there, a lot of fake news.
And I figure if we're
gonna educate the public,
I wanna be involved in this.
So all of the medical stuff that we talk
about on this show, actually, I fact check
and I make sure we're
not doing any fake news
because Lord knows it's hard enough
to see a doctor-
- Which is so important
'cause it's hard to sift
through all the BS sometimes.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- So tell us about the new podcast.
So you talk about real things,
but it's also in a funny way.
- Yeah, so I've kind of been obsessed
with medical stories always.
My favorite part of
like a lot of talk shows
is when people in the public
eye come on and share a story,
hopefully that's funny
and it all worked out.
Those are my favorite kind of stories.
And because of that,
like if I read or hear
of an issue, a medical issue,
I think I'm gonna have
it if I haven't had it.
Like even when COVID started,
I'm walking down the street,
I'm like, did I just get it from that guy?
I feel like that all the time.
And so I'm a self diagnosed hypochondriac.
- I am too.
- And I just added
actor on the end, "HypochondriActor"
and then we met and we're like,
why don't we just do this podcast
that's fun and entertaining
and informative
and it connects people in case you think
you might have something,
it just helps to hear other
people talk about it.
- And if you think you
have something probably,
you'll be able to be like,
it's probably not that.
You know what I'm saying?
- Right, exactly.
- [Kelly] Which is probably
what you say a lot to him.
- All the time.
- A lot of reassurance,
yeah, which is fine.
I love that.
But what I love about the
podcast as well, it's like,
we're talking about
everyday ailments, right?
Like things like diabetes
or anxiety and depression,
but we're also exploring it
from a very non-traditional angle.
Like we do this episode with Kristen Bell
where she talks about
her history of depression
and how she uses psychedelic
mushrooms to work through that.
- Wow.
- Which I never knew and that-
- [Kelly] Very "Fast
Times at Ridgemont High".
- Yeah, well, different purposes, but yes.
That was to get a pizza.
- A lot of people don't know
that there's research out there
with psychedelic mushrooms
and mental health issues, you know?
- Well, to you Dr. Wali, Sean jokes
about his hypochondriac, but it's real.
So how do you deal with that as a doctor?
Because you don't want to tell people,
you know, you're insane,
you don't have that.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't do that.
So look, my kind of philosophy or the way
I approach medicine is whatever
someone's experiencing,
they know their body, even
though I've studied the books
and I've done the years,
you know your body better
than anyone else because
you're the one living in it.
And so when someone's
coming in and saying,
hey, I'm experiencing this pain
or I'm feeling this
anxiety, it's real to them.
- I love that.
And that's what you taught me too.
It's real to the person.
- And so I as a physician
have to believe the patient
and I do.
So whether someone is a hypochondriac,
I mean, I approach it with
curiosity, like, okay,
what is this person really experiencing
that's causing them to have this moment
where they're feeling all these things?
- Right.
I always say, and you can
do this or not do this,
we don't have to,
but just name a part of
the body inside or out,
and I will have a true
story about it on me.
- Well, let's try something then.
- Okay, sure.
- Okay.
I'm gonna name a body part.
- Sure.
- And you tell us what's wrong
or was wrong at some point.
- Ready?
- Name literally anything,
I mean, literally.
- Okay, right nostril.
- Right nostril, you can see it.
You see this right here?
(laughter)
- Wait, what's wrong?
- You see how the there's
extra skin right there
in my right nostril?
- What?
- [Sean] You see?
- No.
Oh! It is turned up a little.
- Yeah, it's like turned up.
So I have-
The camera did that.
- Who in the world would notice that?
- Yeah. Right.
So I had a deviated septum
and I went into this doctor,
it's actually in the first episode
of "HypochondriActor"
where I talk about this.
So I went in to get the
deviated septum fixed.
And I said, while you're down there,
I have a bump on the left side of my nose.
Do you mind getting a twofer
and you know, doing double duty?
He's like salivating.
"Yeah, of course I can get it."
So I did it.
A week later, two weeks later,
whatever, you take the packing out, right?
And he had this little
fetish of like cleaning out
the stuff in my nose.
Like you have to go back and
get all this stuff cleaned out.
Like the mucus, the dried mucus
and the blood that gets stuck in there.
So he has this little tool
and he's like dit-dit-dit,
dit-dit-dit and he's getting
it out and he went bam!
And it's like he hit an artery
and all this blood came
out and I freaked out.
- Of course.
- Yeah, right.
And he's like, "Calm down, calm down.
You need to calm your heart down."
And I'm like,
"You calm down!"
- You calm the hell down!
- Right, it's not your blood.
It's my blood.
He's like, "Get the ER ready."
And my heart races faster,
the more blood coming.
It was all over.
It was crazy, but good thing
I'm here and everything
and they cauterized it and it's fine.
- You do bleed a lot from your head.
I've had an injury in my
head as well right here
late at night and I've bent down.
I was just putting
something down and I hit
something really sharp.
I bled so much for my head
I was sure I was gonna die.
- Oh my God.
- Okay. Big toe.
Anything wrong with your big toe?
- Big toe right now.
Well, I have plantar fasciitis.
- I do too!
- You do?
- Oh my God, we can't.
(laughter)
We have the same-
- We're almost there!
According to the Biden administration,
we're almost there.
- [Kelly] We're close.
It sucks, it hurts.
- Yeah, it hurts really bad.
And so now it's creeped into
just the ball of my foot
on my right side.
So I have a little pad in there right now.
- I am gellin' as well,
like the commercial.
- [Sean] Oh, you are?
Isn't it crazy?
- I wear things too.
Mine is 'cause I performed
like for a decade barefoot
and I got all these
problems with my feet.
- Oh, right.
- But you know, it was worth it.
I had fun.
So anyway, I love this podcast.
I think it's brilliant.
I think what you said
that's most important
is yes, it's funny, but
it is really important
that people can go somewhere
and get real knowledge
that you can trust and believe
in and check out, you know?
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- Yeah, and I think it's hilarious
that you also did stand-up
while doing it.
- Oh, thanks.
- Isn't that great?
- It's amazing.
- Oh, thank you.
- It's just like, where is all
the time that you did that?
Okay, but anyway, Sean's
podcast "SmartLess"
and "HypochondriActor"
are available anywhere
you get your podcasts.